Jason Stark joins us here on the Rich
Eisen show how you doing Jason rich I am
great how are you doing been too long
been way way way too long awesome to
join you thank you
right back at you okay place into
perspective for me what Otani has done
so far for the angels he's one of the
most talented human beings who has ever
played baseball I think it's that simple
I he throws the baseball a hundred miles
an hour over his first two starts he had
a stretch where 34 consecutive hitters
came to the plate and didn't get a hit
he hit homers three games in a row when
they let him swing a bat he hit a home
run off sigh young Corey Kluber and he's
one of the say 10 fastest players in
baseball I mean we just don't see human
beings who can do the things he's doing
so the question is is how sustainable is
it over a 26 you know weeks over over a
season that goes you know obviously as
many months as it goes well you remember
there was there was quite the frenzy
over the winter he was trying to sign
them and that's why those teams expected
this I've talked to Scouts who watched
him playing Japan 40 or 50 times and
they expected this now look there's a
lot of information in the game it's it's
harder to succeed now than at any time
because if there's any flaw any flaw
that you have the sport will figure it
out and figure it out fast and they will
test you and he will be tested it can't
possibly keep up like this would be the
greatest player who ever lived but can
he sustain it he's 23 years old this is
this is his skill set this is his track
record in Japan I think most people who
have seen a lot of them would be
surprised if he didn't not if he did
give me the odds of this happening Jason
start that your starting pitcher for the
American League all-star team and your
third place hitter for the American
League all-star team starter is the same
guy
seriously I think I hope you're right I
like his chances of making the team at
this rate I I just worried that the
angels might want to step in and say he
can do one of the other not both that
would be awful let's let's start the
campaign right now okay well what's more
likely to happen 20 wins or 30 homers
from him
I will go 30 overs just because nobody
in baseball 120 last year and and you
know the way that pitchers are treated
this year the number of times are
allowed to go through the lineup it's
almost impossible to win 20 anymore
Jason stark joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show the Red Sox are on fire right
now they came back from five runs down
in the eighth inning to win their eighth
of nine games to start
are they the team along with Houston
which one's better in this league do you
think well I would take Houston I you
know I was I saw the Red Sox only lost
on an opening day in Tampa Bay they
shouldn't lost that game gave a bullpen
gave up six runs in the eighth inning
that day was kind of a mirror image of
what happened yesterday
they've taken advantage of a soft
schedule Rays and Marlins that's it
that's all they've played but they I
mean they've got a real advantageous
schedule for the most part over the
first 40 games or so so they're they're
good they're they're way better than
they're given credit for they kind of
got lost in the Yankee hype machine but
if you're gonna ask me who who's the
best team on paper and the American link
yeah I can't find a weakness in the
Astros can you know I know they're
they're so good and I love their manager
but again the way that the angels are
playing
I mean if itani is and you know pools
has shown up as well in the first 10
games trout hit one that's still
traveling yesterday I'm telling you this
is fascinating I think Houston has some
competition in the AL West
obviously the Yankees are playing 500
ball right now
their bullpen looks a beatable which is
something that did not happen last
October and I mean Stanton somebody Buck
Showalter walked judged to get to
Stanton
that actually happened yesterday really
he's got 20 strikeouts seven hits two
singles I mean that's his deadline hey
you know he gets himself into these
things he gets himself out of these
things but right now you can pitch to
that guy if you had your choice of which
of those two behemoths to pitch to you
would pitch to Jung Carlo did that ever
happen in Miami I mean once where
somebody was intentionally walked to get
to him well he you know he had a stretch
two years ago where he went
I remember this right was was over 48
with 26 strikeouts he couldn't be much
more lost than that he you know he got
himself into a zone last year when he
closed up his stance where it hit he had
a home run every day you know he had
what 18 home runs in one month and
baseball just doesn't work that way he
he can't find that sweet spot right now
and when he does he ties himself up he
gets himself out he swings and misses
over and over and that's what you're
seeing now but I mean he's one
adjustment away from turning right back
into Babe Ruth and you know you he's the
second guest on my baseball story show
and you know we taped this recently and
just to give you a little sneak preview
Jim thinks he can hit a hundred homers
I'll pick the under but that's what he
told me well not swinging like that I
mean no you know as a Yankee fan he look
he looked right now he looks like Jesse
Barfield with with without many holes in
his swing
I'll be honest yeah I mean Bart Jesse
Barfield was the king of swinging at
pitches that were spinning 19 feet out
of his own and
you know but he could also bop you know
I mean look obviously we're real early
and before we do get to talking about
your show on Stadium baseball stories
the Gabe Kapler gets booed and it seems
to me like again you know the Phillies
it's that they're three and five it's
it's not a complete disaster out of the
gate like say Tampa or or Cincinnati San
Diego which lost in a way that a Pop
Warner team loses and Houston on a pop
fly and the tenth inning
in between the catcher and the pitcher's
mound but here Jason the reason why I
bring all of this up is have we seen are
we at the spot where managers who are
being hired for their analytics have no
field they are not going gut they're not
going hard they're just going straight
by the book are we seeing that right now
well if you're referring mostly to Gabe
Kapler or or Aaron Boone in a way
obviously he's he's made a couple of
moves that have left some people
scratching heads on occasion as well no
you're you're talking about guys who had
never managed a meaningful baseball game
until last week and you know I'm willing
to allow both of them a learning curve
but it it certainly shows up when
millions of people are watching and
that's what we've seen it you know I
know I live in Philadelphia I grew up in
Philadelphia and I'm never amazed by
anything that happens and so I'll see I
I know I know that bullying is what
philadelphians do i I've seen it I get
it but this is kind of amazing because
that this is what people in Philadelphia
wanted right they wanted a team that was
new age not old school they wanted a
front office that delved into the data
and they wanted a manager who didn't fit
those traditional old managerial molds
and within a week they decided that's
not what they want at all and you know I
understand that this guy's off to a
rough start I mean he he did some things
in his first week is manager that IV
meant we disagree with that are really
the talk of the sport
but he's different and I think because
he's so different than anybody who's
ever done that job there are people who
are inherently offended by that
in baseball and don't want him to
succeed and I just think some of what
you're seeing is a reaction to that
hmm the athletics and MLB network's
Jason stark your baseball stories
30-minute episodes on Stadium every
single Tuesday night on watch Stadium
calm first up is Mark McGwire old buddy
of mine from back in the Sports Center
days how open is Mark about the past
Jason well I was really grateful that he
was willing to do this rich he's turned
down a lot of requests to talk about
what happened 20 years ago and he said
yes to me and so I you know I let him
reminisce for a while he has a lot of
great memories of that season he's
allowed to have them he was a man in the
middle of a circus but obviously at a
certain point we turn to a topic that
had to come up and that was peds and
when I said to him let's play the what
if game could you have hit 70 home runs
if you had not taken peds everything
about him changed his his demeanor
changed his expression changed the way
he delivered the words changed and he
could not have been more adamant that
yeh could absolutely is what he said and
obviously I pushed back on that and it
was interesting to hear him defend it
his feeling is he was a born home run
hitter he was the moment he came in it
was he hit is how many what 49 home runs
six then he led the league in homers and
slugging in his first year in the big
leagues right that was 11 years before
he broke that record and so he's right
he was he has a case for that he looked
a lot different then he feels that with
everything he's learned about himself
everything he learned about hitting
we could hit 70 home runs I think we all
have reason to be skeptical of that I
pointed pointed out to him on the show
that since there's been testing not only
has no one hit 70 no one has even hit 60
right nobody has come close to this but
his defense of himself is really
interesting and I you know part of my
role in this show is to let people
express themselves and so I did
well I'm biased Jason you know I he
couldn't be one of the nicer guys that
you will ever come across the way again
regardless peds are not when he was
going through the breaking of Maris's
streak he had everybody following him he
had the commissioner following him from
stadium to stadium ending the inning
at-bat to at-bat he had networks
following him he had the Maris family
following him he had his ex-wife and his
son and his ex-wife's new husband
following him and he was as gracious and
perfect a human being is there could be
as he was going through it and I again
you know I've just been biased about him
for years the PD uses beyond
disappointing and upsetting but I do I
don't know why he did it other than the
fact that maybe everyone was doing it
and he was exposed to it in in in
Oakland I don't know why and I guess
that that's a question for the ages
was one of those people following
Miranda hits 17 homers and I agree with
you you know the people who thought he
was not being as accessible to folks
like us as they wanted them to be missed
something important about them he it was
very important to him to be a teammate
and he hated the fact that his team was
not having a good year all these people
were there just to talk to him and there
were 24 human beings around him in that
room he cared about and he didn't want
to be a sideshow and that was the reason
that there were days he just didn't want
to do it but when he did I thought he
was awesome and
you know here's what I would ask you
because I've thought about this myself
III bring it up to my conversation with
him when I covered that story I thought
it was the greatest story I ever covered
the greatest thing I ever witnessed
because that the stuff that you saw the
people who showed up Barbara Walters
came by one day right Bruce Springsteen
was leaning in for batting cage one day
it was incredible with such circus a
huge story every day and now knowing
what we know what happens to those
memories what do we do with them great
no yes it was great it was great it was
great it brought baseball back
I remember Cal Ripken obviously broke
Lou Gehrig's streak and took that took
that lap around Camden Yards and
everybody started healing from the
strike and then McGwire and Sosa hit and
I understand that they were doped up
Sosa still hasn't even come close to
admitting it but it was incredible
McGwire still had to hit the home runs
and now you could sit here and people
might sit here and think hey look he was
he was cheatin etc etc he still did it
he still did it you know I think he only
went one day with everybody following
him around and he broke that record and
it was and it was all over after that
and in the home run derby with the
all-century team at the all-star game in
Fenway Park I'm getting goose bumps
talking about it yeah where he hit all
those home runs and is at bat in the
home run derby and he broke his bat in
the middle of it I remember that I was
doing which stuart scott and i were
interviewing the players as they were
coming off of their at-bats he broke his
bat in the middle of it and still hit
all those home runs it was remarkable
Ted Williams coming out and asking him
about hitting at the pitcher's mound
it's as great as it is and I will always
cherish it Jason and I'm not embarrassed
to say it
Ramar you're really gonna love this show
then I did let him reminisce and his
memories are happy memories he you know
however conflicted people like us might
be trying to figure out what to make of
it now he doesn't share that you know he
remembers it as a as a great summer well
that's an awesome experience that's
tomorrow night 7:00 to 7:30
p.m. every Tuesday night on watch
Stadium comm Jason don't be a stranger
let's do this on the regular okay I miss
chat rich rich that'd be awesome it was
a total pleasure
likewise right back at you at Jason s T
on Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience